i got you all right there has been a
boom in retro music sales and if you're
searching for a classic vinyl zia
records will most likely have it jc is
at their new location with details on
their grand opening
hey guys eastern and warm springs is the
new location and and z records does have
something for everybody including ted
florendo i know for a fact that this is
his favorite band of all time journey
their greatest hits ted they got it for
you and also i know that ted loves air
supply i found a copy of air supply i'll
bring it back to the studio just for you
ted now i want you guys this is ray we
were talking to her earlier what could
everybody expect at the grand opening on
saturday so the grand opening um like i
mentioned there's going to be a giveaway
for the first 100 people in line
after the giveaway we are gonna have
some community partners come down we're
gonna have critical care comics down
here we're gonna have a rope cutting
ceremony we're gonna have djs all
throughout the day um so starting at
noon ending at around six o'clock we're
gonna have three set up djs for every
couple of hours so it's gonna be a
really fun day it's gonna be a party
it's open right now but the grand
opening is on saturday you have records
you've got cds you've got cassettes as
well and let's talk about some of the
most iconic albums of all time grammy's
in town this weekend michael jackson in
thriller he won for record i'm sorry
album of the year back in 1984 and this
is such a classic album cover little fun
fact this is not his suit this was the
photographer's suit he liked the
photographer suit so much he said take
it off put it on me i'm gonna wear the
suit and then also back in 1984 on the
back of the album the little bar code
there was an urban legend that that was
michael jackson's actual phone number
and people were calling this number but
it was a beauty salon in california not
michael jackson's phone number
let's turn around the corner here
because you have cassettes there you've
got books you've got if you're into like
band clothing you've guys got everything
here at zero records absolutely what is
your news can be made here what is your
favorite album of all time my favorite
album of all time i have two so the
first is hotel california by the eagles
so yeah that's like the first album i
can remember loving as a kid me and my
dad listening to it in the car all the
time so definitely a favorite my second
favorite album of all time hansen middle
of nowhere uh grammy nominated didn't
win but grammy nominated
favorite band of all time so
that's what's so great about record
stores like zia records people love
music and there's a story behind
whatever album someone loves there's a
story behind a song there's a story
behind a record the grand opening is
saturday zia records brand new location
eastern and warm springs i'm bringing
these albums back to you guys in the
studio
nice nice i didn't